here's your money briefing for Friday
July 7th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
more Americans are losing their home
insurance coverage wsj personal finance
reporter Veronica dagger is here to
discuss what homeowners can do to avoid
non-renewal of their policy so Veronica
let's just start with the basics what is
home insurance typically cover a
standard policy typically covers the
cost of replacement of the home and some
of its contents in the event of damage
or theft and in most cases in Most
states you'll need to have home
insurance if you have a mortgage
so why are some homeowners seeing their
coverage not renewed and where's this
happening most often damage from extreme
weather Rising lawsuits in certain
States The Soaring costs of rebuilding
due to inflation has led some major
insurance companies to stop renewing
existing policies or issuing new ones
homeowners in Florida Louisiana and
California have been particularly hard
hit but there's areas across the country
that are seeing and I'm hearing people
in New Jersey Long Island Texas North
Carolina also getting these non-renewal
notices in your reporting you spoke to
some of these people were they taken by
surprise it depends so I spoke to a
gentleman who lives not too far from Los
Angeles he got 30 days notice in most
cases you need to either get 30 or 45
days notice that your policy is not
being renewed so you can scramble to
find someone else but he lives right in
an area that gets a lot of wildfires and
so he had heard some of his neighbors
were getting non-renewed and so he
thought it might be coming but he was
really disappointed to find out that he
was in fact non-renewed and he initially
missed their letter telling him that it
was not being renewed because he said it
was a very nondescript letter he thought
it was some sort of junk mail and then
he opened it and he was like oh gosh
this is something I need to act on you
mentioned that they could find somebody
else could they shop around for another
company you can try to shop around for
sure in his
in his eight farm he was very lucky
though his new neighbor had told him hey
look I was just insured by State Farm
here's my contact try my insurance agent
there State Farm accepted him but soon
after that State Farm actually pulled
out of his area and is not renewing or
writing new policies in his neighborhood
and so so much of this is Tiny you can
shop around but you have to do it
quickly if you get that non-renewal
notice you do not want to wait because
this is such a fast-moving landscape
right now
how common is this insurance companies
not renewing people's policies it's
getting more and more common as more
extreme weather takes hold more events
happen in nature that are wiping out
people's houses the insurers face more
losses and we're hearing that this is
going to become more of an issue as the
year goes on and the years go on having
home insurance may not necessarily be
the easiest thing to get and may not be
a given in certain places some insurers
just don't want to be bothered you know
not renewing someone's coverage seems
like an extreme step why don't the
insurance companies just raise the
premiums they are doing that too so in
certain cases they're raising the
premium so high to effectively cancel
people because if your premium goes from
I don't know seven thousand a year to
fourteen thousand dollars a year some
people especially senior citizens may
not be able to afford that and so you
are effectively dropped some people will
tell me so they are raising premiums but
it's also a cost benefit issue some of
these insurers saying we're just not
making enough money here to justify
staying in business in this neck of the
woods because the claims have just
skyrocketed in the last 10 20 years
because some of these extreme weather
events so short of moving what can
someone do to their home to lessen the
chances of their insurance being dropped
you want to make your home more disaster
resilient and you that mostly on outside
of your home
but on the inside you can do too so if
you live in an area that has a lot of
wildfires you want a clear vegetation to
make this defensible space around your
house inside the house you want to
install safety devices that use smart
technology Leak Detection sensors if
you're in risk of a flood even smart
thermostats may help you stay insured
make sure your insurance company knows
you're doing all these things because
not only will they be more likely to
keep you around but you might even get a
discount in certain markets it's not so
much widely the case anymore getting
these discounts but it may help you stay
on the books you can do other things
like updating your roof installing
hurricane shutters and fire resistant
siding can also help you stay in short
and be the difference between you
getting renewed or not now you mentioned
that in some states people are required
to have insurance but other people might
decide you know what to sidestep all
this trouble they might just stay in
their home without insurance what are
the risks of doing that there's a lot of
risks because if you don't have home
insurance your home is destroyed by a
fire for example you could lose your
house and everything in it not to
mention you may have to pay to remove
your home's remains and all the costs to
rebuild it that's a massive loss
especially when you think about most
people the majority of their wealth is
tied up in their homes so this could be
financially devastating for folks
almost any kind of insurance the costs
keep escalating how are these weather
events and other things affecting the
numbers in this situation the national
average for home insurance based on a
250 000 in dwelling coverage Rose 20
this year and that's to
1428 annually from 2022 and that's
according to bank rate those numbers
keep increasing certain states that are
at high risk are going to have those
higher premiums and so if you're in a
situation where your premiums are so
high and you can no longer afford home
insurance I hate to tell people you
still really should make this a line
item in your budget that is necessary
and figure out where else you can cut if
that's possible
so in the most extreme cases where this
is happening how can the state step in
and help people well if you can't get
private insurance you may turn to your
state that might be the last resort for
people and there's these things called
FAIR Plans which is also known as Fair
access to Insurance requirement plans
and they are State mandated property
insurance plans that provide coverage to
individuals who are unable to get
insurance in the regular Market all
states have some version of this
although they vary in terms of coverage
state by state the trick is with these
though they are typically more expensive
than private insurance plans and they
also more narrowly Define coverage and
so you're going to be paying more for
Less coverage so it's not the perfect
solution but it's better than nothing
that's Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Veronica dagger and
that's it for your money briefing this
week we get a production assistance from
Jayla Everett our supervising producer
is Melanie Roy and our executive
producer is Chris zinsley I'm your host
J.R Whalen thanks for listening and have
a great weekend
thank you